well there's uh two categories of folks
that you outline that uh that worry
about or highlight the risks of AI and
you highlight a bunch of different risks
I would love to go through those risks
and just discuss some brainstorm
which ones are serious and which ones
are less serious but first the Baptists
and the Bootleggers what are these two
interesting groups of folks
who are who who worry about uh the
effect of AI and human civilization or
say they do say okay
yes I'll say they do the Baptist worry
the Bootleggers say they do yeah um so
the Baptist and the Bootleggers is a
metaphor from economics um from what's
called development economics and it's
this observation that when you get
social reform movements
um in a society you tend to get two sets
of people showing up arguing for the
social reform
um and the the term baptism Bootleggers
comes from the American experience with
alcohol prohibition
um and so in the 1900s 1910s there was
this movement that was very passionate
at the time which basically said alcohol
is the evil and it's destroying Society
um by the way there was a lot of
evidence to support this
um there were very high rates of very
high correlations then by the way and
now between race of physical violence
and alcohol use almost all violent
crimes have either the perpetrator or
the victim are both drunk almost all if
you see this actually in the work almost
all social harassment cases in the
workplace it's like at a company party
and somebody's drunk like it's it's
amazing how often alcohol actually
correlates to actually just dysfunction
of these two domestic abuse and so forth
child abuse and so you had this group of
people who were like okay this this is
bad stuff and we should Outlaw and and
those were quite literally Baptists
those were super committed you know
hardcore Christian activists in a lot of
cases there was this woman uh whose name
was Carrie Nation
um who was this older woman who had been
in this you know I don't know disastrous
marriage or something and her husband
had been abusive and drunk all the time
and she became the icon of the Baptist
uh prohibitionist and she was legendary
in that era for carrying an ax
um and doing you know completely on her
own doing raids of saloons and like
taking her acts to all the bottles and
things and back and and so so a True
Believer an absolute True Believer
um and with absolutely the purest of
intentions and again
there's a very important thing here it
which is there's you could look at this
cynically and you could say the Baptists
are like delusional you know extremists
but you could also say look they're
right like she was me you know she had a
point like she wasn't wrong
um about a lot of what she said yeah but
it turns out the way The Story Goes is
it turns out that there were another set
of people who very badly wanted to
outlaw alcohol in those days and those
were the Bootleggers which was organized
crime this stood to make a huge amount
of money if legal alcohol sales were
banned um and this was in fact the way
the history goes is this was actually
the beginning of organized crime in the
U.S this was the big Economic
Opportunity that opened that up
um and so they went in together
um and then they didn't go in together
like the Baptist did not even
necessarily know about the Bootleggers
because they were on their moral Crusade
The Bootlegger certainly knew about the
Baptists and they were like wow this is
these people are like the great front
people for like you know it's good PR
Shenanigans in the background yeah and
they got the full stud Act passed right
and they did in fact ban alcohol in the
U.S and you'll notice what happened
which is people kept drinking like it
didn't work and people kept drinking
um the Bootleggers made a tremendous
amount of money um and then over time it
became clear that it made no sense to
make it illegal and it was causing more
problems and so then it was revoked and
here we sit with legal alcohol 100 years
later with all the same problems
um and you know the whole thing was this
like giant misadventure uh the Baptist
got taken advantage of by the
bootleggers and the Bootleggers got what
they wanted and and that was that the
same two categories of folks are now uh
sort of suggesting that uh the
development of artificial intelligence
should be regulated 100 yeah it's the
same pattern and the the economists the
same pattern every time like this is
what happened with nuclear power this is
what happened which is another
interesting one but like yeah this is
this happens dozens and dozens of times
um throughout the last hundred years and
and this is what's happening now and you
write that it isn't sufficient to Simply
identify the actors and impugn their
motives we should consider the arguments
of both the Baptists and the Bootleggers
on their merits so let's do just that
risk number one
uh will AI kill us all yes
so
uh what do you think about this one this
this what do you think is the core
argument here
that uh the development of AGI perhaps
but I said uh will destroy human
civilization no first of all you just
did a sleight of hand because we went
from talking about AI to AGI
is there a fundamental difference there
I don't know what's AGI uh what's AI
what's inside I know what AI is AI is
machine learning
I think we don't know what the bottom of
the well of machine learning is or what
the ceiling is right because just uh to
call something machine learning or just
to call some of the statistics or just
to call it math or computation doesn't
mean you know uh nuclear weapons are
just physics so it's it it's to me it's
very interesting and surprising how far
machine learning no but we knew that
nuclear physics would lead to weapons
that's why the scientists of that era
were always in this huge dispute about
building the weapons this is different
ages different as machine learningly do
we know we don't know but this is my
point it's different we actually don't
know but and this is where you the
sleight of hand kicks in right this is
where it goes from being a scientific
topic to being a religious topic
um and that's that's why I specifically
called out that because that's what
happens they do the vocabulary shift and
all of a sudden you're talking about
something totally that's not actually
real well then maybe you could also uh
as part of that Define the Western
tradition of millennialism yes end of
the world apocalypse apocalypse Cults um
well so we live in we of course live in
a judeo Christian but primarily
Christian kind of saturated you know
kind of Christian post-christian
secularized Christian you know kind of
world in the west
um and of course Court of Christianity
is the idea of the second coming and and
you know the revelations and you know
Jesus returning and thought the
Thousand-Year you know Utopia on Earth
and then the you know the Rapture and
like all stuff you know we don't we you
know we collectively you know as a
society we don't necessarily take all
that fully seriously now so what we do
is we create our secularized versions of
that we keep we keep looking for Utopia
we keep looking for you know basically
the end of the world and so what you see
over over decades is basically a pattern
of these sort of of these of these of is
this this is what calls are this is how
Cults form as they form around some
theory of the end of the world and so
the people's Temple calls the Manson
called the heavens gate called the David
koresh called it you know what they're
all organized around is like there's
going to be this thing that's going to
happen that's going to basically bring
civilization crashing down and then we
have this special Elite group of people
who are going to see it coming and
prepare for it and then they're the
people who are either going to stop it
or are failing stopping it they're going
to be the people who survive to the
other side and ultimately get credit for
having been right why is that so
compelling do you think like uh because
it satisfies this very deep need we have
for Transcendence and meaning
that got Stripped Away when we became
secular yeah but what why is the
Transcendence involved the destruction
of human civilization because like how
like how plausible it's it's like a very
deep psychological thing because it's
like how plausible how plausible is it
that we live in a world where
everything's just kind of all right
how exciting is that right but that's
more than that but that's the Deep
question I'm asking why is it not
exciting to live in a world where
everything's just all right does it I
think uh you know most of the animal
kingdom would be so happy we just all
right yeah because that means survival
why are we uh maybe that's what it is
why are we Conjuring up things to worry
about so C.S Lewis called it the
god-shaped hole so there's a god-shaped
hole in The Human Experience
Consciousness Soul whatever you want to
call it where there's got to be
something that's bigger than all this
there's got to be something Transcendent
there's going to be something that is
bigger right bigger the bigger purpose a
bigger meaning and so we have run the
experiment of you know we're just going
to use science and rationality and kind
of you know everything's just going to
kind of be as it appears and a large
number of people have found that very
deeply wanting and have constructed
narratives and by the way this is the
story of the 20th century right
communism right was one of those
communism was a was a form of this uh
Nazism was a form of this
um you know some people um you know you
can see movements like this playing out
all over the world right now so you
could start the kind of devil a kind of
source of evil and we're going to
transcend Beyond it yeah and the
millinarians the millionaire is kind of
when you see a millionaire and cult they
put a really specific point on it which
is end of the world right there there is
some change coming and that change
that's coming is so profound and so
important that it's either going to lead
to Utopia or hell on Earth right
um and it is going to and then you know
it's like what if you actually knew that
that was going to happen right what
would you what what would you do right
how would you prepare yourself for it
how would you come together with a group
of like-minded people right how would
you what would you do would you plan
like hashes of weapons in the woods
would you like you know I don't know if
let's create under underground bunkers
would you you know spend your life
trying to figure out a way to avoid
having it happen yeah that's a really
compelling exciting idea to uh to have a
club over to have to have a to have a
little bit of trial like a get together
on a Saturday night and drink some beers
and talk about the the end of the world
and how are you you are the only ones
who have figured it out yeah and then
and then once you lock in on that like
how can you do anything else with your
life like this is obviously the thing
that you have to do and then and then
there's a psychological effect you
alluded to there's a psychological
effect if you take a set of True
Believers and you leave them to
themselves they get more radical right
because they self-radicalize each other
that said yes it doesn't mean they're
not sometimes right yeah at the end of
the world might be yes correct like they
might be right yeah but like we have
some pamphlets for you
I mean there's I mean we'll talk about
nuclear weapons because you have a
really interesting little moment that I
learned about in in your essay but you
know sometimes it could be right yeah
because we're still you were developing
more and more powerful Technologies uh
in this case and we don't know what the
impact they will have on human
civilization well we can highlight all
the different predictions about how
we'll be positive but the risks are
there
and you discuss some of them well the
Steel Man the steel man is the Steel Man
actually the steel man and his
refutation are the same which is you
can't predict what's going to happen
right you right you can't rule out that
this will not end everything right but
the response to that is you have just
made a completely non-scientific claim
yeah you've made a religious claim out
of scientific claim how does it get
disproven there is and there's no by
definition with these kinds of claims
there's no way to disprove them yeah
right um and so there's no you go right
on the list there's no hypothesis
there's no testability of the hypothesis
there's no um way to falsify the
hypothesis there's no way to measure
progress along the arc like it's just
all completely missing and so it's not
scientific and well I don't think it's
completely missing it's it's somewhat
missing so for example the the the the
people that say AI is going to kill all
of us
I mean they usually have ideas about how
to do that whether it's the paperclip
maximizer or um you know it escapes
there's mechanism by which you can
imagine it killing all humans models and
to you can disprove it by saying there
is um
there's a limit
to uh the speed at which intelligence
increases
maybe show that uh
the the sort of rigorously really
described model like how it could happen
and say no there here's a physics
limitation there's a physical limitation
to how these systems would actually do
damage like human civilization and it is
possible they will kill 10 to 20 percent
of the population but it seems
impossible for them to kill uh 99
there's practical counter arguments
right so you mentioned basically what I
described as the thermodynamic counter
argument which is sitting here today
it's like we're with the evil AGI gets
the gpus yeah because like they don't
exist so you're gonna have a very
frustrated baby evil AGI who's going to
be like trying to buy Nvidia stock or
something to get them to finally make
some chips um right so the the serious
form of that is the thermodynamic
argument which is like okay where's the
energy going to come from where's the
processors are going to be running where
is the data center going to be happening
how is this going to be happening in
secret such that you know it's not you
know so so that's a practical counter
argument to The Runaway AG I think I
have a but I have a and we can argue
that discuss that I have a deeper
objection to it which is it's this is
all forecasting it's all modeling it's
all it's all huge future prediction it's
all future hypothesizing it's not
science
sure it is not it is it is the opposite
of science so the Carl Sagan
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof right these are
extraordinary claims the policies that
are being called for right to prevent
this are of extraordinary magnitude and
I think we're going to cause
extraordinary damage and this is all
being done on the basis of something
that is literally not scientific it's
not a testable hypothesis so the moment
you say AI is going to kill all of us
therefore we should ban it or that we
should uh regulate all that kind of
that's when it starts getting serious or
start you know military airstrikes and
data centers oh boy right
and like
yeah this one is get starts well so it
starts getting real so here's the
problem of millionaire and Cults they
have a hard time staying away from
violence
HIPAA violence is so fun
if you're on the right end of it they
have a hard time avoiding violence the
reason they have a hard time avoiding
violence is if you actually believe the
claim right then what would you do to
stop the end of the world well you would
do anything right yeah and so and this
is where you get and again if you just
look at the history of millionaire and
Cults this is where you get the people's
Temple and everybody killing themselves
in the jungle and this is where you get
Charles Manson and you know setting in
need to kill kill the pigs like this is
the problem with these they have a very
hard time to run the line at actual
violence and I think I think in this
case there's they're I mean they're
already calling for it like today and
you know where this goes from here is
they get more worked up like I think
it's like really concerning okay but
that's kind of the extreme so you know
the extremes of anything I hope I was
concerning
it's also possible to kind of believe
that AI has a very high likelihood of
killing all of us
uh but there's and therefore we should
uh maybe consider
uh slowing development or regulating so
not violence or any of these kinds of
things but it's saying like all right
let's let's take a pause here you know
your biological weapons nuclear weapons
like
this is like serious
stuff we should be careful so it is
possible to kind of have a more rational
response right if you believe this risk
is real believe yes so is it possible to
be have a scientific approach to the the
prediction of the future I mean we just
went through this with covet yeah what
do we know about modeling
well I mean what do we learn about
modeling with covet uh there's a lot of
lessons they didn't work at all
they worked poorly the models were
terrible the models were useless I don't
know if the models were useless or the
people interpreting the models and then
the centralized institutions that were
creating policy rapidly based on the
models and leveraging the models in
order to support their narratives versus
actually interpreting the error bars and
the bottles and all that kind of stuff
what you had with my view you had with
confidence you have these experts
showing up and they claim to be
scientists and they had no testable
hypotheses whatsoever they had a bunch
of models they had a bunch of forecasts
and they had a bunch of theories and
they laid these out in front of policy
makers and policymakers freaked out and
panicked right and implemented a whole
bunch of like really like terrible
decisions that were still living with
the consequences of
um and there was never any empirical
Foundation to any of the models none of
them ever came true yeah to push to push
back they were certainly Baptists and
Bootleggers in this in the context of
this pandemic but there's still a
usefulness to models no I I so not if
they're I mean not if they're reliably
wrong right then they're actually like
anti-useful right they're actually
damaging but what do you do with a pen
endemic what do you do with the were
they at with any kind of threat don't
you want to kind of have um
several models to play with as part of
the discussion of like what the hell do
we do here I mean do they work because
they're an expectation that they
actually like work that they have actual
predictive value
I mean as far as I can tell with covet
we just saw the policy makers just Psy
up themselves into believing that there
was I mean look the scientists the
scientists were at fault this is the
quote unquote scientists showed up so I
had some insight into this so there was
a remember the Imperial College models
out of London were the ones that were
like these are the gold standard models
yeah so a friend of mine runs a big
software company and he was like wow
this is like hope it's really scary and
he's like you know he contacted This
research and he's like you know do you
need some help you've been just building
this model on your own for 20 years do
you need some who did you like our
coders to basically restructure it so it
can be fully adapted for covet and the
guy said yes and sent over the code and
my friend said it was like the worst
spaghetti code he's ever seen that
doesn't mean it's not possible to
construct a good model of pandemic with
the correct error bars with a high
number of parameters that are
continuously many times a day updated as
we get more data about a pandemic I
would like to believe when a pandemic
hits the world the best computer
scientist in the world the best software
Engineers respond aggressively and as
input take the data that we know about
the virus and I'm put say here is here's
what's happening in terms of how quickly
it's spreading what that lead in terms
of hospitalization and deaths and all
that kind of stuff here's How likely how
contagious it likely is here's how
deadly likely is based on different
conditions based on different ages and
demographics and all that kind of stuff
so here's the best kinds of policy it
feels like you could have models
machine learning that like kind of they
don't perfectly predict the future but
they they help you do something because
there's pandemics that are like
uh
meh they don't really do much harm and
there's pandemics you can imagine them
they could do a huge amount of harm like
they can kill a lot of people so you
should probably have some kind of data
driven models that keep updating that
allow you to make decisions on base like
where how bad is this thing uh now you
can criticize
how horrible all that went with the
response to this pandemic but I just
feel like there might be some value to
models so to be useful at some point it
has to be predictive right so and so and
and so the easy thing for me to do is to
say obviously you're right obviously I
want to see that just as much as you do
because anything that makes it easier to
navigate through Society through a
wrenching you know risk like that is you
know that sounds great
um you know the the harder objection to
it is just simply you are trying to
model a complex dynamic system with 8
billion moving Parts like not possible
very tough can't be done complex systems
can't be done uh machine learning says
hold my beer but well it's possible no I
don't know I would like to believe that
it is yeah put it this way I think where
you and I would agree is I think we
would like we would like that to be the
case we are strongly in favor of it I
think we would also agree that no such
thing with respect to covet or pandemics
no such thing at least neither you nor I
think or where I'm not aware of anything
like that today my main worry with the
response to the pandemic is that uh uh
same as with aliens is that even if such
a thing existed and it's possible it
existed
the the the the policy makers we're not
paying attention like uh there was no
mechanism that allowed those kinds of
models to percolate up oh I think we
have the opposite problem during covet I
think the policy makers I think the
these these these people with basically
fake science had too much access to the
policy makers
well right and what but the policy
makers also wanted they had a narrative
in mind and they also wanted to use
whatever model that fit that narrative
to help them out so like it felt like
there was a lot of politics and not
enough science yeah although a big part
of what was happening a big reason we
got lockdowns for as long as we did was
because these scientists came in with
these like Doomsday scenarios that were
like just like completely off the hook
scientists and quotes that's not
quote-unquote that's not okay let's give
love so here's science that is the way
out science is a process of testing
hypotheses yeah modeling does not
involve testable hypotheses right like I
don't even know that my I actually don't
I don't even know that modeling actually
qualifies in science
maybe that's a side conversation we
could have some time over a beer uh it's
a really interesting but what do we do
about the future I mean what what so
number one is when we start with number
one humility it goes back to this thing
of how do we determine the truth number
two is we don't believe you know it's
the old I've got a hammer everything
looks like a nail right
um I've got oh uh it's one of the
reasons I gave you I gave Alex a book
um uh which is the topic of the book is
what happens when scientists basically
stray off the path of technical
knowledge and start to weigh in on
politics and societal issues in this
case philosophers philosophers but he
actually talks in this book about like I
talked about the nuclear age and
Einstein he talks about the physicists
uh actually uh doing doing uh very
similar things at the time the book is
when reason goes on holiday philosophers
and politics by uh Nevin and it's just a
story it's a story there's there are
other books on this topic but this is a
new one that's really good it's just a
story of what happens when experts in a
certain domain decide to weigh in and
become basically social engineers and uh
and the political um you know basically
political advisors and it's just a story
of just unending catastrophe
right and I think that's what happened
with covet again
yeah I found this book a highly
entertaining and eye-opening read filled
with the amazing anecdotes of
irrationality and craziness by famous
recent philosophers after you read this
book you will not look at Einstein the
same oh boy yeah don't destroy my heroes
anymore
um I'm sorry you shouldn't read the book
all right but here's the thing the AI
the AI risk people they don't even have
the covet model
at least not that I'm aware of no like
there's not even the equivalent of the
government model they don't even have
the spaghetti code
they've got a theory and a warning and a
this and that and like if you ask like
okay well here's here's the I mean the
ultimate example is okay how do we know
right how do we know that an AI is
running away like how do we know that
the film takeoff thing is actually
happening and the only answer that any
of these guys have given that I've ever
seen is oh it's when the loss rate the
loss function in the training drops
right that's when you need to like shut
down the data center right and it's like
well that's also what happens when
you're successfully training a model
like
like what what even is this is not
science this is not it's not anything
it's not a model it's not anything
there's nothing to arguing with it it's
like you know pushing Jello like there's
what do you even respond to uh so did
you put pushback on that I don't think
they have
good metrics of yeah wonderful is
happening but I think it's possible to
have that like I just just as you speak
now I mean it's possible to imagine
there could be measures it's been 20
years no for sure but it's been only
weeks since we had a big enough
breakthrough in language models we can
start to actually have this the thing is
the AI Doomer stuff didn't have any
actual systems to really work with and
now there's real systems you can start
to analyze like how does this stuff go
wrong and I think you kind of agree that
there is a lot of risks that we can
analyze the benefits outweigh the risks
in many cases but the risks are not
existential yes well not not in the food
not in the phone paper clip now so let
me okay there's another sleight of hand
that you just alluded to there's another
sleight of hand that happens which is
very I think I'm very good at the
sleight of hand thing which is very not
scientific so the book super
intelligence right which is like the
Nick bostrom's book which is like the
origin of a lot of this stuff which was
written you know whatever 10 years ago
or something so he does this really
fascinating thing in the book which is
he basically says
um uh there are many possible routes to
machine intelligence um to artificial
intelligence and he describes all the
different routes to artificial
intelligence all the different possible
everything from biological augmentation
through to you know all these different
things
um one of the ones that he does not
describe is large language models
because of course the book was written
before they were invented and so they
didn't exist
in the book he just he describes them
all and then he proceeds to treat them
all as if they're exactly the same thing
he presents them all as sort of an
equivalent risk to be dealt with in an
equivalent way to be thought about the
same way and then the risk the
quote-unquote risk that's actually
emerged is actually a completely
different technology than he was even
imagining and yet all of his theories
and beliefs are being transplanted by
this movement like straight on this new
technology and so again like there's no
other area of science or technology
where you do that yeah like when you're
dealing with like organic chemistry
versus inorganic chemistry you don't
just like say oh with respect to like
either one basically maybe you know
growing up and eating the world or
something like they're just going to
operate the same way like you don't but
you can start talking about like as as
we get more and more actual systems that
start to get more and more intelligent
you can start to actually have more
scientific arguments here like you know
high level you can talk about the threat
of autonomous weapon systems back before
we had any Automation in in the military
and that would be like very fuzzy kind
of logic but the more and more you have
drones that are becoming more and more
autonomous you can start imagining okay
what does that actually look like and
what's the actual threat of autonomous
weapon systems How does it go wrong and
still it's it's very vague but you start
to get a sense of like all right
um it should probably be illegal or
wrong or not allowed to do like
Mass deployment of fully autonomous
drones that are doing aerial strikes oh
no on large areas I think it should be
required right so that's no no no I
think if you're required that only
aerial vehicles are automated
okay so you want to go the other way I
want to go the other way so that okay I
think it's obvious that the machine is
going to make a better decision than the
human pilot
I think it's obvious that it's in the
best interest of both the attacker and
the defender and Humanity at large if
machines are making more of these
decisions and not people I think people
make terrible decisions in times of War
but like there's a there's ways this can
go wrong too right well the words go
terribly wrong now
this goes back to the this is that whole
thing about like this Ultra it is the
self-driving car need to be perfect
versus does it need to be better than
the human driver yeah does the automated
drone need to be perfect or does it need
to be better than a human pilot at
making decisions under enormous amounts
of stress and uncertainty yeah well the
on average right the the worry
that AI folks have is the runaway
they're going to come alive right then
again that's the sleight of hand right
or not not come alive well no hold on a
second you're becoming do you lose
control but then they're going to
develop goals of their own they're going
to develop them under their own they're
going to develop their own right no more
more like uh Chernobyl style meltdown
like uh just bugs in the code
accidentally you know Force you the the
results in the bombing of like large
civilian areas okay into a degree that's
not possible
um in the in the current uh military
strategies well actually we've been
doing a lot of mass bombings to cities
for a very long time yes and a lot of
civilians die a lot of civilians died
and if you watch the documentary The Fog
of War McNamara it's been a big part of
it talking about the firebombing of the
Japanese cities yeah bringing them
straight to the ground right the
devastation in Japan American Military
uh firebombing the cities in Japan was a
considerably bigger Devastation than the
use of nukes right so we've been doing
that for a long time we also did that
Germany by the way Germany did that to
us right like that's an old tradition
the minute we got airplanes we started
doing indiscriminate bombing so one of
the things we're still doing it the
modern U.S uh military can do with
technology with automation but
technology more broadly is uh higher and
higher Precision strikes yeah well so
Precision is obviously and this is the
the jdam right so there's this big
Advance this big Advance um called the
JDM which basically was strapping a GPS
transceiver to uh to a to an unguided
bomb and turning it into a guided guided
bomb and yeah that's great like look
that's been a big advance but and that's
like a baby version of this question
which is okay do you want like the human
pilot like guessing where the bomb's
gonna land or do you want like the
machine like getting the bottom twist
destination
that's a baby version of the question
the next version of the question is do
you want the human or the machine
deciding whether to drop the bomb
everybody just assumes the human's going
to do a better job for what I think are
fundamentally suspicious reasons
emotional psychological reasons I think
it's very clear that the machine's going
to do a better job making that decision
because the humans making that making
that decision are god-awful just
terrible yeah right and so so yeah so
this is the this is the thing and then
let's get to the there's can I one more
slide of hand okay please I'm a magician
you could say one more sleight of hand
these things are going to be so smart
right that they're going to be able to
destroy the world and wreak havoc and
like do all this stuff and plan and do
all the stuff and evade us and have all
their secret things and their secret
factories and all this stuff but they're
so stupid that they're going to get like
tangled up in their code and that's
they're not going to come alive but
there's going to be some bug that's
going to cause them to like turn us all
into paper like that they're not gonna
they're gonna be genius in every way
other than the actual bad goal
and it's just like and that's just like
a like ridiculous like discrepancy and
and and you can prove this today you can
actually address this today for the
first time with llms which is you can
actually ask llms to resolve uh moral
dilemmas yeah so you can create the
scenario you know dot dot dot this that
this that this that what would you as
the AI do in the circumstance and they
don't just say Destroy All Humans
Destroy All Humans they will give you
actually very nuanced moral practical
trade-off oriented answers so we
actually already have the kind of AI
that can actually like think this
through and can actually like you know
reason about goals well the the hope is
that AGI or like a very super
intelligent systems have some of the
Nuance that llms have and the intuition
is they most likely will because even
these llms have the Nuance uh elements
are really this is actually worth worth
um spending moment on LMS are really
interesting to have moral conversations
with and that
is I didn't expect I'd be having a moral
conversation with a machine in my
lifetime well and let's remember we're
not really having a conversation with a
machine where we're having a
conversation with the entirety of the
collective intelligence of the human
species exactly yeah correct but it's
possible to imagine autonomous weapon
systems that are not using llms but if
they're smart enough to be scary
why are they not smart enough to be wise
like that's the part where it's like I
don't know how you get the one without
the other is it possible to be super
intelligent without being Super Wise
well you're again you're back to that I
mean then you're back to a classic
autistic computer right like you're back
to just like a blind rule follower I've
got this like core is the paper clip
thing I've got this core Rule and I'm
just going to follow it to the end of
the Earth and it's like well but
everything you're going to be doing
execute that rule is going to be super
genius level that humans aren't going to
be able to counter it's just a it's a
it's a mismatch in the definition of
what the system is capable of unlikely
but not impossible I think but again
here you get to like okay like no I'm
not saying when it's unlikely but not
impossible if it's unlikely that means
the the fear should be correctly
calibrated extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof